تعرض الرئيس الاسبق زين العابدين بن علي
المحاوله اغتيال في السنوات التي عاملت
فيها معه
في السنوات التي عملته فيها معه همم
محاوله اغتيال المحاوله الوحيده هي ما
الاغتياله همم خطر قبل كنت هنالك محاوله
انقلاب ان سمي بالمجموعه الامنيه مبرمجه
اليوم
وسبقها التغيير الذي قام به الرئيس
اعتمادا على الدستور
دائما
في بدايه التسعينات
بعد توتر الامور
وبعد انتخابات 89 في بدايه التسعينات
وزاره الداخليه انذاك
اعلنت ان هنالك
مجموعه تعد
لاعتداء
بتوجه نحو الطرف من اطراف الخارج للحصول
على صاروخ ستينجر
لاستهدف الطائره الرئاسيه الى اخره هذا
هذا ما طرح انا ذاك ولست ادري همم اين
وصلت الامور في التتبع الموضوع هذه هي
محاوله المحاوله الوحيده محاوله اغتيال
الوحيده هذا ما اعلمه لا اعلم غيرته وهل
ايضا هي التي تتحمل المسؤوليه ذلك
الذي اتهم انا ذاك من قبل الوزاره من قبل
التحقيقات او المعلومات التي توفرت والتي
جاءت في بيان من الداخليه
التوجيه الاصبع الاتهام كان الى
على الاقل جناح في الحركه الاسلاميه